Let's talk about designing a
socially critical data science
course. I have for
you a play in 3 acts.
Act One: teaching about
wealth inequality.
Act Two: data analysis
for social action.
And Act Three: specific
resources to help you teach.
Here's act one.
Welcome to your first
day of my class.
The very first thing we do is
that everyone gets one penny.
An actual physical penny.
The very next thing that
we do is offer a prediction
about the following:
Everyone's going to do one
trade with a classmate.
With your penny.
How do you trade?
You find another student,
you bet against them
on a random outcome event, like
a coin flip or rock, paper,
scissors.
And the loser pays the winner
one penny.
Here's an abstract view of what
my classroom would look like.
Two students would find
each other and pair up.
There's one penny at stake.
They're going to compete
on a random outcome event
and bet on the odds.
And the loser is going to
pay the winner one penny.
So this happens
across the classroom
simultaneously with different
students in different pairs.
Before trading,
we're all equal.
If you were to look at a bar
graph of everybody's wealth,
it looks really uninteresting.
Everybody's got one unit
of money, it's a penny.
And we've ordered these
completely randomly.
But each agent, as
it were, has a bar.
So the first question
I ask before we even
do the trade is what's going
to happen after everyone
does one trade?
And I'd like you
to imagine that.
You each have a
penny. You're going
to match up with somebody else.
You're going to
bet on something.
A coin flip is pretty handy
because you both have pennies
and the loser is going
to pay the winner
one penny.
So what happens
after that happens?
Is that half the people
in the room go broke.
And half the people in the
room double their money,
instantly, with one trade.
Then you ask what happens
after lots of trades?
That starts to look
like this where
you can see that a few people
have most of the wealth
and there's even
one person who's
got 5 pennies, which
means they quintupled
their initial investment.
But 71% of the people in
this simulation are broke.
Not poor, not
impoverished, broke.
Here's another case
of us running it
with slightly different rules
and a greater money supply.
I like this one a lot.
It shows the same features.
We have a few people
with most of the wealth.
But then you have people
who go below the zero line
with -20 wealth that
they finished with.
And you might be
saying to yourself,
is that an error in the
graph or what happened?
Loans happened.
We allowed students to
loan money at interest.
So they could loan four pennies
with the expectation
of getting five back,
I think was the rule
for that simulation.
And the very first outcome was
that the students constructed
their own subprime loan crisis.
Nobody was checking credit.
So I watched one student
hit the same person up
for like five loans, and when
she denied him a sixth loan,
he walked across the
classroom and found
somebody else who didn't
know him and got more loans.
The second outcome is that the
students discovered the value
of a distribution graph.
So these bar graphs have
the advantage of simplicity.
But every time we
run the simulation,
we can't predict who's going
to get most of the money.
We just know that it's
going to concentrate.
And I do this on
purpose because I
want them to see that it's
very difficult to predict
the outcome of a bar graph.
But if there's some
underlying property that
says, oh, most of the money
is going to go to the few,
that's the value of
a distribution graph.
That one distribution
graph can represent
so many different situations.
So ultimately, we can't predict
which agents will go broke,
but we can predict
that most will.
Finally, I think it's important
that a seemingly fair system
can still produce
unfair results.
It seems fair because
the coin toss is fair
and everybody has an equal shot.
But it's not fair because broke
people routinely get denied
the opportunity to trade again.
If you had money, why would
you trade with a broke person?
You have a 50% chance of losing
some money and a 50% chance
of getting no money.
That's it.
So broke
people stay broke and they
stay out of the simulation
ultimately.
Here's Act Two: data
analysis for social action.
So when I was teaching
at Michigan state,
a very local crisis was getting
international attention,
and it had to do with the
poisoning of the water supply
in Flint, Michigan.
Flint is about an hour
away from East Lansing,
which is where I was teaching.
The super short version
is that to save money,
the city of Flint
decided to stop importing
water from the Great Lakes
and divert the
Flint River instead.
And the Flint river's
toxic corrosiveness
leached lead out of the pipes.
This was happening while
we were teaching the course
and a data set had just
come out from folks
at Virginia Tech who had
sent at-home testing kits
to 270 families in Flint to get
readings on their lead water levels.
And we had students analyze
this and write about it.
Here's one example
of a student analysis
where what they've
done is try to compute
the number of samples that
exceed the EPA'S action limit.
So the EPA says if more
than 10% of your samples
are above this
threshold, which happens
to be .015 milligrams per liter,
I think, you've got a problem.
And a student wrote some
code to count up how many
of the raw samples there are
that exceed that amount,
as well as the percentage
that exceed that amount.
The other thing I want
to point out to you
is it's difficult
to see perhaps,
but that distribution
has a real long tail.
And there are some folks
out there at 0.2 --or, sorry--
0.12 or 0.14
6 to 8 times the
legal limit for lead.
That's a huge problem.
So we had our students write
to the governor of Michigan
with their analysis results.
And here's an example student one.
"I constructed a histogram.
"I also wrote a simple
program to compute
"the number of samples and the
percentage above the limit.
"45 samples exceeded
the EPA limit,
"making this 16.6% of the
samples above the action limit.
"This indicates the seriousness
of this problem and exactly
why we need to urgently
take action to help Flint."
Act Three: resources
to help you teach.
You might be asking,
what can I do?
So I have three pieces
of advice that I'm
going to go into detail on.
The first is try to choose
data and activities that
question systems of power.
The second is do what you can
to make bias issues in your data
known and check for them.
And the third, which I think
is arguably the most important,
is to adopt a critical
framework to analyze and expose
oppression.
So first up, you should
use the opportunity
of being able to choose
data sets for your class
to analyze, to ask what issues
demand our attention socially.
Now, I don't want to
stand here and say
that every activity that you
do must always be focused
on improving the social good.
But I think even if you
started with one activity,
you'd find it has
a ripple impact,
and it gets you thinking about
more data that can do this,
and it gets your
students thinking
about more ways they
can try and help society
through the newfound
powers they're
learning in your courses.
Second, you can check
data for biases.
You can ask "Who is being
disadvantaged in this data?"
And so,
A tool for that is IBM's AI 360
I've got the
link down there,
but also I'll have a
QR code you can scan,
which has all the links that are
related to this presentation,
so don't panic.
The AI fairness 360
has some demo data
that you can take a look
at, and this is an example
of what it can produce for you.
This data was analyzed and
has a privileged group,
which happened to be females
and an unprivileged group,
which happened to
be males because we
have representational
issues of unequal weighting.
So the tool goes on
to determine things
like what would the statistical
parity difference be?
What's the equal
opportunity difference?
What's the average
odds difference?
And then it goes so far
as to offer strategies
for addressing that bias.
These are two of the
automated strategies
that it proposes: reweighting
and optimized pre-processing.
I think a third is
adversarial learning,
but I don't know that much
about adversarial learning, so
don't quote me on that.
But the idea is
that the tool lets
you see where your data might be
leading you to conclusions that
are steered by biases
that in most cases,
we want to correct for, and
it offers automated solutions
for doing so.
My third point is about
adopting a critical framework.
I think it's so important
to recognize that data
analyses are not value neutral.
So this is a book called
Data Feminism that came out
in 2020 from MIT Press.
You can read the
entire thing for free
at their website, which again
will be in my list of links
in my QR code thing.
Here's a quote from a
description of the book.
"Illustrating data
feminism in action,
"D'Ignazio and Klein
show how challenges
"to the male/female
binary can help
"challenge other hierarchical
(and empirically wrong)
classification systems."
It's a little jargony.
So let's do this.
Raise your hand if you've
either seen or yourself done
gender as a dichotomous
variable (0 or 1).
Right, so what happens when
your gender is not captured
by 0 or 1 or male or female?
Well, you could add
another option like
non-gender conforming.
But what happens if your
gender is just non-binary
or your gender is gender fluid?
You could add
options until the cows
come home.
Really,
what's being revealed to
you is an oppressive system
that is forcing people
into categories that they
don't necessarily identify with
or is forcing them to exclude
themselves from the
data analysis entirely
just by not answering
the question.
And D'Ignazio and Klein are trying
to point out it's stuff
like that that we might not even be
consciously aware of if we're
not thinking for it.
That can have huge
impacts on the people
we're asking questions of.
My final example comes
from mapping Detroit.
I call this redlining in action.
This was a map that
was produced in 1929
by an all-white, all-male
Chamber of Commerce
and a majority white/male
Federal Home Loan Board.
The purpose of the
map was to figure out
neighborhoods where it
was risky to offer people
loans and neighborhoods where it
was safe to offer people loans.
The effect of the map is
that an already racially
segregated demographic
is now disproportionately
affected by people's decisions
not to lend to, for example,
Black people.
Because
Excuse me, because those
were deemed neighborhoods
where it was risky to lend.
So can you imagine if your
credit worthiness depended
not on yourself, but
on who's next to you?
Imagine how that
crushes social mobility.
reifies social order.
D'Ignazio and Klein say "Early
20th-century redlining maps
"had an aura very similar to the
'big data' approaches of today.
"These high-tech,
scalable 'solutions'
"were deployed across the nation,
"and they were one
method among many
"that worked to
ensure that wealth
remained attached to the
racial category of whiteness."
That wealth remained attached
to the racial category
of whiteness.
I think it's worth
asking if that's
what data science was doing
then, what's it doing now?
Thanks, folks.